which is the start of my 20 rules for
fundraising
number one we need to make it fun and as
fun as possible
it will take a toll on you mentally so
you need to operate through storytelling
and community building to do all that
you need to build the foundation of your
community
by telling a compelling story and
fundraising is all about storytelling
storytelling is what your brand and
company stands for
the boring way to think about this is
through your tam and your moat
but let's stop using this as a key
selling point for your company
it can be a bullet point on your deck
but focus on telling
your story but why do it like this
why storytell the golden circle is the y
my
number three rule do not sell your
business on the how or the what
sell it on the y this is the beginning
of building your personal community
but let's break that down real quick the
three parts the golden circle
the why why do you do what you do what
is your purpose
how do you do what you do and what do
you do
the how and the what are incredibly
boring
and seen all the time and hard to
connect to
on on a personal level you need to make
yourself stand out
my fourth rule tell your story and why
your company
and your vision matter investors see
hundreds of decks so why
bore them with the same promises of
hypotheticals a massive tam or projected
revenue
the why is much more interesting my
fifth rule
take an example from shopify president
harley and this very simple tweet
shopify is not a technology company we
are the entrepreneurship company we
enable people to achieve their own
unique version of success
could you imagine if shopify's pitch
deck
and they're raising money today by
selling the what and the how
shopify is an application programming
interface platform and app
that allows you to create an ecommerce
website boring
it's very boring and easily forgettable
talking about your why resonates and
builds a connection with your community
of investors
what's easily forgotten is tam what's
not forgotten is a captivating why
rule number six this is a fundamental
rule
that you need to value investors are
your personal community
that is the mentality you should take
into fundraising there are people too
and who you surround yourself with
matters rule number seven
and to that point whatever idea you have
in your head right now
around your ideal cap table just throw
it out and forget it because you're
probably wrong
you don't know the world and you need
time to explore it
once you realize you're building
community and you throw out this perfect
cap table you have in your head
rule number eight comes in and it's not
about the money you need to get that out
of your mind
yes you are here to fundraise capital
for your business but this cannot be
the decision maker for who you work with
uh the money
will only get you so far rule number
nine
find the investors who can bring you and
your company value
every investor can write a check but can
they also bring you
value rule number ten which leads to
something very important to me is when
something goes wrong and you need help
will that investor support you ask
yourself that question when you are
making decisions on
who to cut or who to make room and
squeeze into your round
you need a support system through thick
and thin so do your own reference checks
and rule number 11 something you should
never forget vcs invest
in the founder just as much as business
this is why building your community
matters and why money should not be the
leading decision maker for you
ask yourself who do you want to surround
yourself with because
they are asking themselves the same
question
and just as important rule number 12 you
need to inspire
because fundraising can be a long
process you need to plant your seeds
telling your why through storytelling is
what's important because with time
and investor updates that why will
inspire and resonate
it might not be a yes today but it could
definitely be a yes tomorrow
and when you do get those no's rule
number 13
your investor updates are your best
friend keep your nose
if they initially pass ask them if they
want to be put on a monthly investor
update
i converted two of my biggest seed
checks from no's to a resounding
and impactful yes over the course of
five monthly
investor updates and just as important
when you are saying those invest dates
uh investor updates
rule number 14 don't blast all bcc to
your warmest leads
start every email with something
distinct that will help you
stand out and show that you know that
email you was written for just them
and not a hundred other people and one
way to do that is follow your potential
investors on social media
or listen to them on youtube you can
take those learnings
uh such as something they might have
tweeted and something they're talking
about on twitter
and use that in your email to open up
the conversation and show them that
you're paying attention
again they're people just like us and
most importantly
fundraising is not a race have some
patience it will take time and your
community will start with one and then
go to two
three four commitments but it will take
time
as much as you nurture the growth of
your business you also need to nurture
the growth of your vc community and if
you do get a no
read the room rule number 17 tap into
your network of no's
there's an opportunity to ask them for
an intro on their network you should do
it
my best intro came from a no and don't
be afraid to ask
if there's a fit for your company with
someone else they might know
the worst that happens is you'll get
another no or no response at all
literally no harm in asking and
naturally with patience and time
the right investors will find out about
your why and your story and it will open
up your network to a fundraising path
you never expected and that will
continue on through
the trajectory of your company and as
your community grows
you need to build fomo
fomo is a combination of two things
telling your story
of why while also showing revenue growth
and progress for your company
those two things will naturally create
fomo as the round comes together and
commitments begin
to trickle in and finally fomo is your
superpower
so be confident and use it use your why
to power your community
use your community to build the fomo and
use your fomo to close
your round